good morning and good afternoon to
everyone kind of in the global audience
welcome to the GCP online Meetup my name
is Nick Korolev I am one of the Google
cloud customer engineers based out of
the Bay Area and today we have a super
awesome talk that were jazzed about
talking about the hidden cost of cloud
with one of our customers server density
but first your you want to introduce
yourself real quick for anyone who's new
sure I post really happy to be here as
Nick's co-host my name is Yuri I am
another customer engineer and we're
coming to you today from the music
bracket studio here at YouTube which is
always a fun fun time unfortunately I
don't have any opening riffs for you so
I'm sorry for that
yeah well it'd be much worse if I had
any alternate riffs I can't play
anything so you guys unfortunate cool
and we also have David Myton David
you're with server density you are the
CEO and co-founder and you want to
introduce yourself real quick yeah
that's right I'm I'm David I'm founded
and built the original version of seven
density in 2009 and it is a
software-as-a-service performance
monitoring product awesome so just out
of curiosity software-as-a-service
monitoring products can be very broad as
conclude so would you mind taking maybe
a couple minutes and explain like what
it is that you guys monitor today and
and how you're helping us um cause some
customers whether they be cloud or
on-premise and your overall solution
joso live identity is primarily an agent
based monitoring product which means we
have a small piece of software which you
install onto your servers
we're completely agnostic about where it
might be although nowadays most of our
customers are running in the cloud but
the agent
runs its collects core system stats and
send it back to us
so that we can show graphs and we can
trigger alerts manage your
infrastructure feedback we ever need on
that chance we do
okay cool well when we switch back and
forth we might have to do worry about
that but awesome so David I really want
to thank you for the time you are based
out of the UK so thank you for joining
at 5 p.m. your time and this is pretty
awesome because this is gonna be a first
international Meetup
where we're talking across the pond I
guess as they say but really the reason
why we reach out to you and the reason
why we want to have this meetup is you
wrote a phenomenal blog that's called
the hidden cost of cloud that's on
medium after this we'll post a link to
it so everyone can read but I was really
hoping that we could spend some time
talking about your experience not only
just migrating to Google cloud but
hopefully an unbiased conversation about
what kind of hidden costs you might be
referring to how you tackled those and
then kind of like how you better
architect for for planning the the
overall TCO and the overall cost of
cloud so I'm good to jump into yeah okay
cool
so maybe first we could talk about what
it is you migrated so I know that you
perform this migration I think it was
either late 2016 or early 2017 so maybe
could walk us through your environment
that you had to migrate some of the
challenges that you encountered and how
the overall experience might sure so
there's two key problems that have been
keeping us working hard on the technical
challenges over the last eight years or
so the first of those is processing
large volumes of incoming data in near
as close as possible to real-time so
that we can trigger alerts for customers
and then the second problem is the
storage of large volumes of time series
data and that's what powers their graphs
for our customers so the two use cases
obviously getting notified when
something is broken but once you've got
that notification you need to be able to
see what's going on so the graphs are
pretty important to any kind of
monitoring products
over the years we've scaled have been
using using a product and having a
stable and high performance time series
database has been a big challenge for us
and we've also had the challenge that at
the time that we were scaling there was
no real product that could solve the
different scaling challenges either as
an open source product we would have to
run ourselves or as a managed service so
through the years we've built our own
things internally and then as services
have become available we've looked at
how we can replace them with something
that's managed for us because we're just
a small team of engineers so this
brought us at the end of 2016 or in 2016
where we were having problems with our
existing time series database we've
built a custom version a custom system
on top of MongoDB it's a very good
general purpose database and has matured
over the years and has scaled with us
with with problems but problems we've
been able to solve but we found that we
were spending a lot of time building
custom code so time series databases is
a very specialist application and we
built our own custom version on top of
[ __ ] so we had to maintain that and
build new features and keep it running
but also scaling the hardware side of
things we were hosted on bare metal
servers and also across a virtualized
environment and we were spending a lot
of money a lot of time managing what had
to be some pretty hefty servers a lot of
SSD storage a lot of RAM and we got to
the point where we're spending so much
time and also cash on the hardware
itself that we decided to evaluate the
options of replacing the custom-built
time series database with either a
product or a managed service so we look
to as many different options as we could
we look to products from Amazon redshift
and also RDS and also open source so
Cassandra my sequel building another
custom version on top of that as many
many companies have done
rewriting it in the latest version of
MongoDB or as as we came to use we also
looked at Google kind of BigTable which
was very early on I am but was looking
promising particularly because it had an
official connector for Open TS DB which
is an open source time series database
that's what the name is and that meant
that we could offload a lot of the
custom feature development to an open
source product so building things like
aggregating data of mathematical
functions dealing with retention of data
that was all part of the standard
feature set of open tiers DB and then
the management of the the actual data
store behind the scenes that could be
handled by Google as a cloud service
because we could just connect the two
together and so our migration over to
Google Cloud started with a single
service open TST be on top of Google
Cloud BigTable as the most expensive and
most time consuming service that we had
to run and then as we completed that
migration that went live in or just over
a year ago February February last year
and having successfully migrated that
running across two different cloud
environments when we then decided that
we would migrate our full workload over
to Google cloud using container engine
compute engine and to cover the
different other products as well so
that's a quick run-through of the
migration story well that's really
interesting and I feel like you're
coming from a position that a lot of our
customers are trying to grapple with is
they have some custom build applications
that are running on premise that they
really see some the value and that might
be their competitive differentiation but
then they also have some kind of more
generic applications that really could
be run anywhere and they're trying to
identify hey do we do a lift and shift
or do we try to rewrite some of our
applications and I know that a lot of
our customers can try to try to grapple
with that but it sounds like you found a
really good medium of identifying your
strengths
server density strengths as well as
school strengths and just being able to
kind of move over which you could and
then optimize everything else in terms
of making it cognitive before moving it
over so since your since you've already
kind of crossed this bridge and since
I'm sure some of our viewers are trying
to debate if they are ready for that
crossing themselves how about any any
any surprises that you've encountered
and and let's keep it keep it unbiased
may be a positive surprise but then also
may be some negative surprises that you
would wish you had known before you
before you did the move yeah absolutely
something the one I focused in on my
blog post is the cost side of things I
think that's really interesting because
people often make the comparison between
collocation buying your own hardware and
actually physically racking it through
two very very cheap dedicated servers
all the way to client environments and
then they're comparable in a way but
really it's not completely appropriate
to compare like for like they're not the
same kind of thing in most cases if
you're just comparing CPU and memory to
in the cloud to what you could buy
Hardware the cloud is always going to be
more expensive it's you don't really get
the cost savings just on the pure dollar
value of the resources that you're
buying the savings that you get are in
the efficiencies of moving core workload
to the cloud so that you no longer have
to manage it and this ikemen comes down
to one of the huge advantages of
BigTable in particular in that we can
get scalability and we know that it's
gonna cost us a very specific amount of
money and it's completely linear and we
can do that the click of a button in in
the clio console or through the API and
that makes the predictability and the
management very very easy I'm just
comparing to hardware is very difficult
to do because all of the added benefits
you get are quite difficult to calculate
so the cost of your team the software
updates management behind the scenes
the cost side of things can be difficult
but with that that caveat and that
that's not you can't really compare them
directly and there are some interesting
features of the cloud and which is
certainly worth highlighting and in
particular it's the granularity of costs
that you get so when you buy a dedicated
server or if you buy my physical server
and Racquet yourself you know that the
probably just can be a single cost it's
gonna be the monthly fee that you're
paying for that server or the one-time
fee that you pay for the hardware itself
plus the the rack itself in the crowd
absolutely everything that you use every
single resource is billed individually
precisely the amount that you're paying
for and it seems like an obvious thing
but it is a shift in thinking when
you're used to just buying a server and
paying fixed amount every month
regardless of the usage and whether
you're maxing out the server or whether
you're not and whereas in the crowd
you're actually paying precisely for the
amount of resources that you're using
and this can be quite difficult to
predict and there are a number of
instances where you can get sudden
spikes of usage that you just weren't
expecting and so for example and if
you're looking at your current
performance so buying storage for
example and with Claire discs you're
often buying certain number of I ops the
the operations it's actually I'm quite
difficult to measure your current
performance to predict exactly how your
workload is going to migrate over from
physical spinning disks or SSDs over to
eye ops in the cloud and it's often that
I ops number is often linked to the
storage volume size at least on on
Google code but also the number of CPUs
and that is unusual and when you're just
buying a dedicated server and we might
not even know the number of biopsies
your purchase and you just know that
with an SSD it's going to be fast and
that has the side effect of sometimes
you're over sizing your instances
because you might not mean the number of
CPUs that you're buying then you might
not need the full volume size that
you're buying but you need to buy
a certain number of i/os so that's one
of the as visit the dam sites in there
the pros and cons of that that's really
interesting so I like how you call that
kind of these unexpected costs things
that you didn't that you didn't really
anticipate so you mentioned kind of the
over-provisioning and how to accurately
monitor or identify how much how much of
a resource you actually require but I'm
actually sharing my screen let me just
jump over into your blog post actually I
did so one of the things I wanted to
call out was kind of the the networking
cost so so you mentioned that everything
in a cloud is billed and it's built
precisely which which makes sense but in
your blog posts you you mentioned that
there was a period of time where all of
a sudden you saw a huge spike in traffic
exiting your network which ended up
costing you some additional funds
through Google and what I like is is
that you and Google were able to work
together and identify that it was fraud
at the end of the day however would you
mind taking a second and just explaining
your your process of kind of identifying
that and how you were able to work with
Google on on getting that resolved yeah
so that's a really interesting example
because it's a good example of abuse or
an unexpected spike and you either got
it as actual abuse that someone is
misusing your service or it's a spike of
traffic because you are suddenly
unexpectedly popular on reddit or I am
on Twitter or something like that and
there's similar use cases although
probably the second one and someone you
want I am as opposed to the abuse use
case and so in this instance and we had
a large spike in traffic to firebase web
site and that we hosted on firebase I am
just as a static site at the server
density calm web site itself and we have
a number of budget alerts set up on the
different projects within Google cloud
so we know
our expected budget is going to be for a
month and we have alert setup so that
and we're reaching it and the percentage
usage should basically match how far
along we are in the month so 15th of
January they are about it should be 50%
usage and so we have this sudden spike
and our alert triggered saying that we
used much more of the monthly budget
than we've been expecting and digging
into the usage graphs we saw that
massive spike that you you showed which
is basically the baseline and our usage
of of the website was completely at the
bottom of the axes on the graph so we
couldn't even see our actual usage
because that massive spike went all the
way up so that was simply a case of
opening a ticket with Google support and
saying this looks like an unusual
traffic spike and not least because it
spiked for a couple of days and then
went back down again and working with
Google supports get into the logs and it
was very very simple they just simply
said this looks like abusive traffic and
we're gonna credit you for it and so I
think just actually raising the issues
first and we Google make sense to do but
having the budget alerts and the the
data and the marching is important so
you can spot these problems yeah that
actually absolutely makes sense and so
you you mentioned keeping an eye on the
budget earning and monitoring of your
existing resources would you mind
talking for a second about what you're
using to do that sure so I just open the
box there are budget alerts available on
google cloud and you can set this up
based on dollar amounts and also
comparisons to your previous bill so you
can get alerts sent out at different
stages throughout the month and of
course the unlimited flexibility is kind
of the whole point of the cloud but it
does mean that you can have a denial of
service attacks on your credit card now
as opposed to just your application and
so it's really important to do that
because as far as Google's concerned
this is just your application running
and it's not something that's
necessarily proactive
monitored by Google and you may end up
hitting your credit card limits and
having a problem at the end of the month
so it's important that you do keep
plowing it so those budget alerts are
important but you can also get the usage
data dumped into CSV and also exported
into Google's bigquery product which is
a great way to run analysis on the raw
data of what's actually happening so you
can analyze that data obviously by
yourself you can just pass the CSV Zoar
query BigTable the query oven and you
can also use the data studio product
which is free as part of the G suite or
Google cloud as part of the Google tools
and which does a decent job but
unfortunately it doesn't support the
discounts that are available on compute
engine so we found the automatic
sustained usage discounts and the
committee juices discounts don't get
plotted correctly and so we're using a
third-party tool now record reoptimize
which basically queries big big query
and visualizes the data for you so we
can keep an eye on almost real-time it's
not quite real-time data but it's
updated I am within a couple of hours up
to 24 hours later so we can keep an eye
on everything that's happening in our
account we can drill down into projects
can drill down into the products and you
can also label the resources on the
Google side so you can categorize and
group all the different things that
you're using and then build reports
based on that interesting yeah that
makes sense
so in your in your blog posts you also
called out the need to search for
discounts so you mentioned like your
customer usage or committed usage and
sustained usage discounts but would you
mind just kind of covering walking
through like what those are and what
kind of discounts that you really look
for sure so the sustained usage discount
so I think one of the best features of
compute engine when compared to Amazon's
ec2 because you don't have to do
anything to get the first level of
discounts
just the fact that you're using compute
engine throughout the month means that
you'll get automatic discounts if you
use it for a certain period of time this
is in comparison to Amazon's reserved
instances which are certainly very
flexible but they're so complicated in
figuring out how how many you need to
buy for which instance types and in
different regions and so with the
sustained usage discounts they just
apply automatically and you get a
discount as you continue to use a
compute engine instance throughout the
month that's really good for usage that
you might not be expecting or as part of
a new application and not something that
you're just learning about but once you
know what your workload is going to be
and you've got static workloads or
workloads you can predict into the
future then you can buy the committed
usage discounts which gives you even
more of a discount you don't have to pay
anything up front but you do get a
commitment so you have to it's basically
contracting for a period of time a year
all three years I think is so thank you
very much for that I wanted to give some
of the folks on our live chat to get
their questions answered and now might
be a good time to ask their first
question you've already talked about
some of the things you're using in GCP
obviously you're running on compute
engine using quite a big table is
obviously a big part of your
architecture and you've already told us
that you're using bigquery for analysis
I realize it may be somewhat difficult
to do without a visual aid but I'm
wondering if you can give us you know a
short summary of what does your
architecture are in GCP it looks look
like what products that you see did are
you really really using yeah absolutely
so the first products that we started
using etc is BigTable and when we move
that use case over and we were at the
point where we needed to rewrite that
project anyway so we were lucky to be
able to spend the time to completely
rewrite like that from scratch to use
container engine to have it completely
containerized and to use all of the core
Google products around it but with the
other the other parts of the application
that we moved over we decided we wanted
to get onto Google as quick as we could
and so we just lifted them directly from
VMs or the bare-metal servers and they
run completely ads compute engine
instances so for many of the systems we
have we're not getting the full
advantage of Google kind and since we're
not using all of the products that we
might use but well that's the direction
that we're going and so the direct lift
from from the VMS and the bare-metal
over to the compute engine instances was
aided because the architectures is a
microservices SACEM so we have worried
15 or 20 or so different services
internally within seven entity that
manage different areas of the
application and these are all made
available internally through an HTTP API
and web UI for customers is built on top
of that with an authentication layer as
is a public API so as a server density
customer if you're using our API you're
using the same API that engineers are
using internally to manage the different
aspects of your can so things like alert
configurations user profiles the
inventory in your account for the
different things resources you're
monitoring these are all based around
api's and the architecture itself is
Mike services and the code is mostly
Python so we have load balancers that
Google load balancer products internally
and we also use nginx in a couple of
different locations and we're running
our own load balancers but our goal is
to move everything over to Google
services so that we can containerize
everything and also take advantage of
things like the pub/sub product which we
will be replaced our plan is to replace
the Kafka and storm setup we have so
when alert payloads come in they get
processed through Kafka as a queueing
system and then we have a number of
different engines which determine
whether an alert should be triggered on
where the data will go so part of it
will go into the alert engine or go into
and to be able to be stored for long
term storage so the plan is to replace
Kafka and with pub/sub at some point so
we kept the full managed service element
to them and so the architecture is ready
I am early sophisticated thank you very
much that actually
I think starts to answer that one of the
other questions that we have on the line
here which is you know how should folks
think about migrating to GCP should they
be like you said trying to get to Google
as fast as possible by simply migrating
their VMs to compute engine should be
should they be reor connecting and we
writing their applications or just
container izing them and it sounds like
you know the path you chose is some of
all of that right and some things you
migrated as they were some things you
ended up rewriting or at least container
izing based on your experience with that
you know we think you would do anything
differently if you were to do it again
any kind of lessons learned from some of
those choices but I think the underlying
principle should be to keep it as simple
as possible because doing a migration to
a new provider is a big task and it's
going to take a lot of time you want to
have as few moving parts as possible so
our initial workload wants to rewrite
and deploy on to BigTable using all of
the Google products around that but we
had no time constraints because this was
the first thing we were testing it out
and we connected Google up to our
previous environment using a secure VPN
and that has its overheads there's
there's a obviously a bandwidth limit
there's a cost to sending data over the
Internet's although it's encrypted you
still have to pay for the data transfer
and there is a small performance hit
because you're moving moving data over
over the Internet and we're really
moving the resources and should be done
as quickly as you possibly can because
of the complexity of doing it and if
you're going to rewrite the entire
architecture at the same time you're
going to end up changing so many
different things it's probably gonna
cause problems excellent thank you so
much and then I'll ask you kind of one
last question which I know may not be an
easy answer that perhaps you answered
this the beginning but you know if you
were to summarize kind of your decision
to choose TCP over AWS you know what
would you say well I could look at the
top two or three top two or three things
that that's wait your decision and also
I would love to hear personally if
there's anything that actually
the decision difficult if there are some
advantages AWS had that you you know
essentially had to trade off in order to
take advantage of the benefits of GCP
yeah so I'm gonna start with the the
second bit because I think it's probably
the most obvious one which is that AWS
is is the biggest cloud and so there are
more people who know about AWS there's
more blog posts as more resources they
have just a bigger ecosystem and that's
that can make a difficult decision and
to go with what I think is actually a
better technology choice because
although Google doesn't have as many
products and when it comes to comparing
the portfolio's of a against AWS the
products that are there I think are much
better designed and much better
implemented just the documentation is
better the API is a better the interface
is better it's much more consistent and
although some features might be missing
the ones that they're the ones you
actually need to use and they they just
work as as you'd expect it to it's clear
been designed from the beginning which I
am everything I suppose has iterations
and AWS has the advantage and also
disadvantage of having been around for a
very long time so they've got legacy
things that don't work quite so
consistently or quite as well-designed
just because they've been built on built
on later
whereas TCP has the advantage of all of
googles experience being able to go into
it from the beginning as a as a newer
product I think the thing that probably
I am stood out the most person where we
had to make changes after migrating was
around networking and the cost of that
we moved from an environment where we
didn't have to pay for any internal
networking at all all the traffic and
was completely free across all of the
data centers that we had and when you
move to the cloud whether it's Google or
any other client provider they all
charge for all of the network usage
outside of a single zone and for the
best practices you have to deploy across
multiple zones and you need to do that
together redundancy and reliability and
ideally across multiple regions but it's
really expensive to do that and
particularly if you have noisy services
internally don't control there's only
like
Kafka and sending the data around
different a different clusters or even
database replication can be very noisy
and you have no real control over that
and it can be a hidden cost that you
might not be expecting that makes sense
and I know that there's quite a few
papers out there that Google's published
that the industry is published on trying
to rationalize building for for best
practices building for high availability
versus kind of building for cost
optimization so it absolutely makes
sense so I know that we're kind of right
up right around the mark so maybe if I
could ask one last question maybe the
the thousand dollar question is did you
find that it was worth it are you are
you glad that you moved over any any
last thoughts that you want to want to
share on that subject yeah absolutely we
are very happy and now that we've moved
on to modern M structure and we can let
Google deal with some of the things that
just have no additional value for us as
a competitive differentiator so scaling
the time series database we don't have
to have to deal with that anymore our
overall cost has been reduced by almost
50% and that's because we're able to get
significant efficiencies from using a
managed service as opposed to having
really beefy hardware which might being
fun to say you've got hundreds and
thousands of gigabytes of terabytes of
SSD and but actually wasn't delivering
enough value for the business we can
also say one modern infrastructure that
is carbon neutral and moving towards
being a completely renewable which is
great for us as a business and our
engineers love being in an environment
that has has modern api's and modern
modern systems and features and so it's
definitely been worth it and yeah I
highly recommend the move cool well
thank you very much for all the feedback
and actually I do have one more question
since you are our customer since you
guys server density are they having some
amazing products that are helping our
customers helping us etc anything in
2018 that we can look forward to from a
server density perspective anything cool
coming down the road so the main thing
is the integration
so we have with various services of
people running so whether that's
software databases web servers anything
you're running in your infrastructure
and also the care providers that you
might be using and we're building
significantly better integrations so we
can pull in data from any of your own
environments and help you visualize a
monitor and making sure that that is is
visualized in interesting ways
graphs are cool but there are other ways
to get the information out of your
infrastructure about what's going on
where the problems are and how to
optimize it so that's what we're
building well that's fantastic
well David I feel like we could talk to
you for so much longer I just love all
the insights that you have you've walked
this path before so thank you very much
for spending the time especially since
it's after hours in the UK right now
but to everyone else who's listening
thank you for for for watching please
remember to rate thumbs up thumbs down
subscribe yeah hopefully thumbs up and
we will we'll see you next time so
awesome thank you so much David Thank
You Yuri thanks for having me thank you
everyone out there see you later